let's imagine a new screenwriter has
their screenplay bought
or optioned so everything's going great
and then they are fired off the project
is this a good thing yes it's an amazing
thing it's how my writing career started
because you're in the system now and
again it's a business
right so you know you do something great
they give you a deal which is awesome
they give you money because that's what
comes with the deal
and that's awesome and then you're in
the mix of it and you're learning
how they operate by the notes that they
give you
and now other people in the industry
know that you're working for this studio
so they're going to want to meet with
you because you're working on this
project that was just announcing the
trades
now people know what's going on with you
like you're in the mix you're in the
game now
and then they get to a point where you
do
the writing and they look at it and they
go
this was my personal experience when i
sold
i would die for you to colombia they
were like wow
this is coming together like we can
start seeing this as a movie
so since we start seeing it as a movie
now let's get some real people in here
to get it done
so they fired us
it's business it's insurance
you know what i mean you're talking
about millions of dollars
you know what i mean most people won't
give their best friend two dollars
right so you're talking about millions
of dollars that are going to be spent
on these 100 and some pages
they need to make sure that that money
is going to turn into more money and
oftentimes with a new screenwriter
that means firing that screenwriter
bringing on a new one
that's already been in the mix maybe
they've written two or three films
that have been greenlit maybe the last
thing that they wrote was a big hit
maybe they wrote and directed a big
indie thing that blew up at sundance
it's an insurance policy for the studio
so the studio feels more comfortable to
go
forward with the piece it's not a bad
thing
it's never a bad thing it's a bad thing
if you look at it like a bad thing
but really it's you're in the mix now
you know what i mean you can take that
sale
and turn it into all kinds of stuff
especially broken record
if you have more material
[Music]
it's so important that's why i keep
saying it it's super important you got
to have more stuff
you know what i mean you just that's
just it's the nature of the beast
it's nature of the beast there are
millions and millions of dollars
to be made
you gotta have more stuff when you're
turning in that first draft
and you're giving it to whomever you're
working with
is it would you say you trust somebody
who's just more brutally honest with you
than somebody who wants to be nice and
keep the relationship going but maybe
they dance around things and they're not
i think you want listen you don't want
somebody that's just going to like
trash you right because that just kills
the confidence
but you also don't want somebody who's
going to like pussyfoot around you
you know and not really give you the
real so i think it really does come down
to
developing relationships with people
through your writing i mean i haven't
always had
the pleasure to be able to just trust
that i can deliver that first draft and
we'll be able to rock out
like i haven't always had that situation
but i have it with these people because
we're just so
keyed into one another like we uh we'll
have meetings
and they'll go for like four or five
hours and we have a blast
you know we all share the same sense of
humor we all share the same
basic you know belief system we all have
the same
basic values we all see the world
essentially the same way
so it is a very unique situation for me
because i trust those guys i can i can
say like
boom here it is this is what i'm
thinking what do you guys think and then
they'll come at me and they'll be like
all right let's do this and this and
this and this and this and this
it's like you know listen it's
absolutely not normal
it's absolutely not the way it goes
but because i have this relationship
with them
if i'm wrong on the first draft all by
myself
i might be wrong on the second third
fourth right
all by myself but because i have this
team that i trust that knows what
i want my end result to be let's give
them the first draft
let's just get on with it if i'm wrong
i'm wrong and you know we'll get to the
point where it's right
and we get there a little quicker than
me sitting around agonizing over
uh am i did i do this right am i wrong
i don't know i have the luxury of not
having
to do that it's nothing i would tell
anybody else to do
it's nothing i would recommend for
anybody else um
i just happen to be very fortunate to
have looked into
the right folks for me
you